We have all heard that behind every
successful story
there is also one full of sacrifices and
that is a true statement
from one of the most
important people at Palace Station that if it
is not like that
sixth day I woke up second virgin the
general manager of the procession who  but the
reason behind his success is the people
those who work with him the
factories this time come as standard and heart
and hearts to see so much with 45 years as
part of life and the community of las
vegas college station what if not  it has
had to adapt and innovate
over time and still maintain its
essence,
that is where the help of everything
that
the
albert sin envers company allows and how it is that everything
tells the story of life behind
station que yes  no
and its people staying relevant in
our current technological world well
I present to you do monte casa
[Music]
nothing represents a celebration like a
big party and its dancing and that is
exactly  mently what all in vision or
when he brought the green ticking where he
tackled a great celebration with dancing and
showing the heart behind the casino
his people
ah it
's a very different atmosphere for
sure because at the end of the day that
atmosphere would be nothing without the members
of the  pau station team and their
guests
[Music]
why sometimes
the report with the spray divert
frankfurt paper machines and must be
revealed for and five years